eigentlich wäre hier viel platz für
einen windpark ein feld am rande der
gemeinde das so in mecklenburg doch
windräder vor der eigenen haustür
dagegen kämpft ihr und kilian seit acht
jahren
der größte sorge ist wenn der windpark
steht dass wir letztendlich eine
komplett andere landschaft erleben
werden dass wir das sind momentan
erholungsgebiet zum windpark sind wir
industriegebiet nach den plänen der
bundesregierung soll die windkraft das
arbeitspferd der deutschen energiewende
sein doch seit jahren gibt es gegenwind
wie in dassow
bundeswirtschaftsminister harbeck erhöht
jetzt den druck auf die länder ihre
ausbauziele zu erreichen bis 20 23
müssen die bundesländer zwischen 1,8 und
2,2 prozent ihrer fläche ausweisen wir
teilen es aber regional schwer auf so
dass man die windhöffigkeit
beziehungsweise die räumlichen ordnung
mit berücksichtigt der ausbau scheitert
oft an abstandsregeln wiener ein windrad
an häusern gebaut werden darf
beantworten die bundesländer
unterschiedlich habe ex gesetz sieht vor
erreicht ein bundesland sein ausbauziel
nicht fällt der mindestabstand weg das
sei nicht der richtige weg kritisiert
sachsens ministerpräsident kretschmann
1000 meter sind aus meiner sicht ein
guter kompromiss der vieles befriedet
hat in den ländern außerdem müssten
direkte anwohner von windparks
finanzielle vorteile haben erklärt
mecklenburg vorpommerns regierungschefin
manuela schwesig
wenn wir jetzt den bürgerinnen und
bürgern mehr zumuten wollen zb kleinere
abstände zu windparks dann sollten wir
denjenigen die die lasten tragen auch
etwas zugute kommen lassen zum beispiel
mit geringeren kosten für den strom das
bundeskabinett soll am mittag habe es
neues wind an land gesetz absegnen
und in erfurt der thüringer
landeshauptstadt begrüße ich jetzt den
ministerpräsidenten bodo ramelow von den
linken einen schönen guten morgen herr
ramelow ich hoffe dass sie mich hören
können jetzt ist der windpark dazwischen
gekommen
darüber möchte ich gerne mit ihnen
sprechen ich hoffe dass sie mich hören
könnte ich stelle mal gleich meine erste
frage die sich um airbags gesetzentwurf
dreht er sich ja vor dieser plan dass
die länder zwar weiter über die abstände
zu windrädern selbst entscheiden und
flächen ausweisen können aber eben nur
wenn dieses im schnitt 2% sie dann
irgendwann auch erreicht wird und wenn
nicht greift der bund ein würden sie das
so akzeptieren
und da wenn es ein bundesgesetz wird
haben wir das zu akzeptieren dann ist es
bundesrechtlich vorgeschrieben aber um
es praktisch zu sagen windkraft in der
jetzigen form ist die preiswerteste form
von energieproduktion unsere thüringer
glasindustrie die vom erdgas abhängig
ist und wir haben den bericht gerade
gehört möchte umstellen auf
stromgetriebene glasproduktion dazu
braucht es mehr regenerative energie im
südthüringer raum da haben wir aber im
moment eine sperre da weil die cdu
durchgesetzt hat dass auf kalamität
flächen also ehemaligen waldflächen die
jetzt abgeholzt worden sind weil der
borkenkäfer alles zerstört hat das auf
diesen flächen keine windkraft aufgebaut
werden darf während wir also den wald
und der ist in thüringen 40 prozent
unserer landesfläche wenn wir den wald
komplett blockieren und den ehemaligen
wald nicht einmal über planen dürfen
dann wird es bedeuten dass der druck der
richtung nordthüringen dann geht doppelt
und dreifach so hoch ist also ich würde
lieber dass wir in thüringen unsere
hausaufgaben selber machen wir hatten
mal den plan ein prozent selber
auszuweisen und liegen im moment nur bei
0,4 das ist viel zu wenig deswegen
brauchen wir jetzt eine energieoffensive
die auch in thüringen breit von den
landräten mitgetragen wird denn unsere
industrie braucht dringend regenerative
energie und dazu nahmen dort ihre
umweltministerin ja ein kompromiss auch
jetzt
präsentiert über den ich noch mal kurz
mit ihnen sprechen möchte nachdem
nämlich an mit abstand von windrädern zu
wohngebieten von 1000 meter gelten soll
auch wenn es einige ausnahmen dazu gibt
reicht das um den ausbau dann wirksam
voranzubringen nur wenn der wald
freigegeben wird als planungs fläche
damit wir auf kalamität flächen ich will
es noch mal sagen kein vitaler baum muss
abgeschlagen werden für eine
windkraftanlage
aber solange wir abgeholzten waldflächen
einfach als tabu zonen bezeichnen werden
wir immer mehr den druck haben das in
siedlungsgebieten windkraftanlagen
aufgebaut das ist ein selbst gemachtes
thüringer phänomen dass wir nur
gemeinsam mit der cdu aufheben können
und deswegen werbe ich jetzt am beispiel
der glasindustrie 7000 beschäftigte in
südthüringen brauchen dringend
regenerative energien und die
unternehmen haben sich dazu bekannt
diesen weg gemeinsam mit der politik
jetzt zu gehen das heißt man muss jetzt
die ärmel aufkrempeln nicht ein habe die
schuld in die schuhe schieben sondern
die praktische arbeit auch vor ort
machen und das bedeutet dass die
thüringer landesregierung die landräte
die raumordnungs region und die
wirtschaft gemeinsam diesen weg jetzt
planen und begehen müssen und am ende
tatsächlich die bürger wo die anlagen
stehen müssen im portemonnaie spüren
dass es zu ihren gunsten ist es kann
nicht sein dass im osten die strompreise
am höchsten sind und gleichzeitig die
bürger nichts davon haben ich möchte
gern mit ihnen noch mal gemeinsam den
blick etwas weiten und auf ganz
deutschland schauen denn es gibt ja auch
die möglichkeit dass die länder laut
diesem gesetzentwurf untereinander
handeln können also jetzt mal als
beispiel berlin und brandenburg rechnen
ihre flächen zusammen dass in
brandenburg mehr und in berlin weniger
anlagen stehen finden sie so eine idee
sinnvoll da in berlin und brandenburg
stehen ja jetzt schon viel mehr anlagen
als in thüringen also diejenigen die im
moment schlusslicht sind ist bayern und
thüringen und markus söder hat jetzt den
weg frei gemacht dass in dem wald auch
im staatswald in bayern anlagen
aufgestellt werden können und in
thüringen wundern sich die waldbesitzer
die dringend darum bitten dass auch
dieser weg geöffnet wird wundern sich
dass das in thüringen immer noch
blockiert ist insoweit kann ich gerne
über so ein handel reden nur tatsächlich
wir haben in thüringen unserer
verpflichtungen nicht noch nicht
eingehalten insoweit halte ich mich
zurück mit kritik an anderen sondern sag
mal wie einige probleme die wir im land
selber jetzt lösen müssen dann noch dass
herr ramelow anfang der woche hat
kanzler chance den ost bundesländern ja
versprochen die bundesregierung werde
den osten nicht im stich lassen beim
thema energieversorgung wenn es kein
russisches erdgas oder erdöl mehr geben
sollte beruhigt sie das sollte erstmal
ein wichtiger schritt gewesen den haben
wir einhellig zusammen festgestellt also
die frage ln sie gas terminal in lubmin
wir haben eben beitrag gehört dort kommt
im moment das erdgas an dort muss damit
ostdeutschland versorgt wird ln sie gas
mit eingespeist werden oder öl an
landung in rostock manuela schwesig hat
gesagt sie sei bereite den weg
mitzugehen weil eigentlich sollte die
ostsee tabu sein für
tankschiffe hat für öl anlandung aber
wir brauchen öl für schwedt und neuner
das ist miteinander besprochen und dann
brauchen wir eine perspektive wie wir
aus der verbrennung von fossiler energie
rauskommen das muss die hauptkraft
anstrengung sein dass wir sagen wir
lassen uns von putin nicht länger
erpressen wir lassen uns auch
kriegsbedingt nicht sonderprofite
einfach den bürgern aus der tasche
ziehen dazu braucht es kraftvolle
schritte und die haben wir als
ost-ministerpräsidenten auch gegenüber
der bundesregierung klar formuliert bodo
ramelow war das von den linken der
ministerpräsident aus thüringen vielen
dank für das gespräch
gerne